[Music]
it seems like everyone has a theory
about what will happen in the highly
anticipated avengers infinity war
follow-up and they're all varying
degrees of plausibly implausible but no
matter how possible or
impossible these theories seem to be
when held up to the light of scrutiny
that doesn't stop us from checking to
see if each one is fresh or a real
stinker
as such the latest avengers 4 theory to
gain traction on reddit
where else has us checking our back
issues to see what's what
user for better worse posted a theory
that claims that characters like the
fantastic four and mutants like the
characters from the x-men franchise have
always existed in the marvel cinematic
universe
but that they'll be introduced into
avengers 4 following a reversal of
thanos's snap that killed half of all
living beings
details of the theory are very very
complicated
in order to work it relies on a few
different ideas for the fantastic four's
introduction the theory relies on super
genius reed richards and the rest of the
ff having been off exploring the
negative zone
unbeknownst to the rest of the world
when the snap is undone they'll be
ripped back into our earth
at which point an already established
fantastic four can rejoin the mcu that
they've secretly
always been a part of the mutants of the
mcu meanwhile have an even more
complicated setup
in the theories telling of the mcu's
hidden history shield of the 1950s and
60s created some kind of bomb to give
people superpowers but
it didn't seem to work then as the
people hit with the bomb's energy past
their slightly altered genes to their
kids
the wave of energy released by the
reversed snap makes the mcu's mutants
or at least that's what it all seems to
suggest
the ins and outs of reddit theories can
be tough to decipher and we won't
pretend to know if we're getting the
thing exactly right
what huh but there's at least a few
kernels of possibility here
for starters as for better worst points
out marvel studios president kevin feige
has hinted that future avenger films
will be more space-centric
if the avengers survive that is that
gives us a clear path for the fantastic
four's arrival from some kind of
extraterrestrial setting
then again this theory is just that a
theory
introducing characters like the x-men
and the fantastic four would definitely
change the mcu in a major way
and fans are driving themselves crazy
trying to figure out how marvel studios
will work them in
now that marvel's parent company walt
disney studios is finally closing in on
acquiring fox and all the movie rights
to marvel characters that it owns
it's really only a matter of time until
the x-men and the fantastic four enter
the mcu and fans definitely expect them
to make an appearance
after all feige once discussed the
importance of featuring new and
different characters and marvel movies
in the future
evolving marvel movies is the most
important thing and that's what you've
seen happen over the past 20 films
different genres different heroes heroes
maybe you've heard of if you'd read
comics
heroes you might not ever have heard of
even if you did read comics but
considering avengers 4
wrapped principal photography ages ago
since directors joe and anthony russo
shot infinity war and avengers 4 back to
back
fans probably won't see hide nor hair of
the x-men or the fantastic four when the
film drops in may 2019
even still there stands a chance that
the avengers 4 story could set up the
possibility of that happening somewhere
down the line
and it has happened before don't forget
the aftermath of the first avengers film
with all the dead aliens and leftover
tech
led to the events that created vulture
in his crew in spider-man homecoming
despite writer-director joss whedon
having no idea that sony and marvel
would ever work out their differences to
bring spidey into the mcu
it worked then so it can probably work
now
so how will the fantastic four the x-men
and the rest of marvel's mutants make
their way to the mcu
well we've got a big purple dude who can
snap his hot dog fingers and change the
very fabric of reality in an instant
so it really doesn't need to be any more
complicated than that if you think about
it with your brain that is
the brain is a muscle and that's a
muscle and that's a muscle
and they're all muscles this is all
muscle so i
am covered in brains and i have more
brains than you